longtime jeopardy host Alex Trebek says  he will be back on the air soon after an  operation to remove blood clots in his  brain in a video posted online the 77  year old Trebek said he was injured in a  fall about two months ago surgery was  performed after two days in the hospital  I came home to start recovery the  prognosis is excellent and I expect to  be back in the studio taping more  jeopardy programs very very soon  certainly concerning Trebek his host of  the legendary game show since 1984 he  did not give a specific date for his  return in my in my house we were always  allowed to we weren't allowed to watch a  lot of TV but we were allowed to watch  jeopardy oh yeah just came on so we were  able to watch what is jeopardy  I've asked it with the question or else  you don't win they get the push balls  right